so the Trump Biden cocaine story is
sadly being repeated and actually
growing I told you not long ago that
Donald Trump kind of alluded to Joe
Biden maybe being on cocaine he's now
talking about it as if it's fact and he
did this during a recent interview with
this guy Wayne Allen root Wayne Allen
root is a guy who've I've interviewed
several times years ago he would ask to
come on the show regularly and I would
have him and the conversations were sort
of like okay he's a friend of Trumps and
listen to this Trump just casually says
we can't have a president who's on
cocaine and Wayne Allyn root goes right
as if this is now just a foregone
conclusion you guys might say wait is
there any evidence that Joe Biden's on
cocaine No in fact they always talk
about how low energy he is cocaine would
not make you seem low energy uh but now
they're just casually mentioning this
like it's fact and we can't have a
president that's on cocaine when you're
dealing with nuclear weapons everything
else you know right we're dealing if you
heard me say that right president see
all these guys these are at the top of
their game these are smart whether you
like them or their country more praise
of authoritarian leaders you are there
at the expense of our democratically
elected president their policies you
know which are pretty tough policies but
these people are at the top of their
game mentally and we have a guy who in
his best years was at the top of the
game and we all right so now it's just
hey you we can't have a president on
cocaine right no no no we absolutely
can't in general this interview on real
America's voice was a combination of
cluelessness virtue signaling and
throwing red meat out there and
seemingly unable to resist this topic
Donald Trump again bringing up the
rigged election and actually putting
forth this is so narcissistic and so
egocentric that it's actually stunning
Trump says if the election hadn't been
rigged and I had become the president
nobody would have died in Ukraine as a
result of Russia's Invasion what what
listen if if the election weren't rigged
all of those dead people from Ukraine
and from Russia and from everywhere all
of those people would be alive today all
of those cities would be standing they
were beautiful you could never rebuild
them this is the height or the bottom
depending on your perspective of
narcissistic egocentrism and I don't
know where this goes next because it's
getting as bad as it has ever been
really weaponized narcissism and people
like way now and root they just lay down
and allow Trump to walk all over them
and go right yeah we can have a
president on cocaine that's very very
bad IO the question about Trump debating
I increasingly don't know how Trump
debates because the the way that he
comports himself even among other
Republicans seems like it would be
self-inflicted damage and by the way we
just learned that Chris Christie has
secured enough one-time donors to make
the debate stage on August 23 yet
another reason that it seems Trump would
hesitate to debate let's actually talk
now about the continued triggering of
Trump by Chris Christie if you're like
me and you love The Nostalgia of
enjoying a bowl of cereal sometimes as
an adult check out our sponsor magic
spoon magic spoon is the breakfast
cereal with the crunchy sweet goodness
you love but with zero grams of sugar
more protein and only four to five net
carbs so it's perfect if you're doing
low carb if you're doing keto if you're
like me and you just don't want to eat a
bunch of sugar magic spoon has delicious
flavors to choose from cocoa fruity
frosted peanut butter Honey Nut cinnamon
roll birthday cake my favorite is maple
waffle and right now they have limited
edition spring flavors strawberry
milkshake and peaches and cream
sometimes you just feel like sitting
down with a bowl of cereal when the mood
strikes go for something with plenty of
protein
without all the sugar if you don't love
magic spoon as much as I do and our team
does magic spoon will refund all of your
money no questions asked go to
magicspoon.com Pacman create a custom
bundle use the code Pacman for five
dollars off the link is down below